steamed ham army where's my where my
steamed ham army hey my steamed ham army
at
[Music]
burger scholar George remotes is what
you call a road warrior he's logged
thousands of miles in his car chasing
down burgers all over the country and
today I'm lucky enough to be his
co-pilot and he takes me through one of
the most important roots in hamburger
history in the most unlikely of places
Central Connecticut it's home to some of
the most unusual burgers on the planet
as well as the birthplace of the
original hamburger barely any clouds in
the sky the sun's out awesome day for a
road trip I do this all the time and I
love it
I I feel the most comfortable in my car
driving to eat burgers now that we're on
this like burger quest I mean I'm with
the man in Connecticut in Connecticut
and your license plate even says
hamburger on it hey why are we here
Connecticut is a very unique place for
hamburgers because it really was the
birthplace of manufacturing in America
Connecticut has a very very strong
hamburger working at Woking man food
burgers make sense first makes sense
you've done this before but you're
showing me where it all started it what
started but also where how and why it
started here well how does this you know
hamburger culture proliferate in a place
that is you would normally think of you
think of New York City I think of
California think of Chicago you would
know I think of Connecticut but people
definitely should today we're going to
Louie's lunch and New Haven Connecticut
Ted's restaurant in Meriden Connecticut
which is the home of the steamed
cheeseburger which will be and then of
course Shady Glen
it's a mid-century diner that looks like
it is lost in time
[Music]
this place is I believe the most
historically significant hamburger
restaurant in America it's because it
has actually been the longest
continually operating hamburger
restaurant in America it's been around
for 118 years being in here this is like
eating at a museum yeah basically you
read it you're actually in the cradle of
hamburgers yeah man I'm excited to try
everything Louise lunch turned the
century this place was a horse-drawn
hamburger cart there were some Hamburg
steaks which is something you ate to the
fork and a knife on a plate but a guy
came in he was in a rush apparently
these guys said hey we'll put it on some
toast for you and he ran out the door
and that was it the hamburger apparently
at that point was born now there are
earlier claims to the hamburger that
happened at state fairs in the Midwest
maybe a few years earlier 1020 years
earlier but this is the actual
documented case of a hamburger being
invented at a place that has never
stopped serving hamburgers you ready I'm
ready you're gonna be kind of blown away
by its simplicity I I can't wait the big
reveal yeah I'm is nothing to it look at
to basically it think of a grilled
cheese with the hamburger strip in the
middle of it
Wow
you know this is all about the burger
because the first thing you get his beef
is beef flavor he's got to start with
two balls and come together to make a
single patty it's actually pressed into
this cage and then it's cooked from the
sides and an upright barometer no cheese
they can't put cheese out because that's
actually sitting squeezed in this cage
upright cook sideways to these cheese
spreads they put cheese bread on the
toast
they keep by that this also predates the
hamburger bun by easily by 12 more than
20 years the toast has a toaster for the
bunny's toaster goes back to the 20s
yeah so cooking in this kitchens like
cooking it like a vintage car garage
that's you know if you have your
old-school Enzo Ferrari I've never seen
other boroughs like this in America I
mean as a burger historian like yourself
you probably want to have one of those I
would love to have one job you can see
this dude's house
I got a lot of blood contractions in my
ass fourth-generation proprietor today
you heard your background talking to
George and now George is a great guy
what do you really think of number one
rule at being in Louise's don't be an
[ __ ]
period that's what it should be like
that in every restaurant but it can't be
goddamn Yelp is you know whatever it's
right between reviews and all that crap
you can't do it but you're an [ __ ] in
this place you're out if you're an
[ __ ] this place we don't belong here
anyway exactly simple as that you want a
brioche bun get the hell out of ya that
this is not the place for that this is
for an honest meats cheese onion tomato
yes
burger sandwich pit stop number one New
Haven Connecticut Louise lunch the home
of the og burger you're the Roadmaster
yeah any rules to the road that I need
to get about hard and fast rule this is
I really am very serious about this no
farting at red lights no farting the
only fart when the cars moving and then
you have to roll the winner no dutch
ovens jeffers number two I come and
drive like a maniac and no complain
about my driving
what I was saying about the front of a
place don't judge a book by its cover
right don't judge this place this is
test the esteem cheeseburger did not
start a test but this is arguably the
best place at this point to get the best
primary source example of the team
cheese and you're telling me this in
season one right like this is like a
regional favorite five mile radius this
place is everything customers their
steamers are all custom-made their
spatulas where they pull the meat out
are all custom-made it's just a
one-of-a-kind burger stand really where
does it come from like it's a good
question I don't really not only know do
you know the real origin stories now do
you know we don't see no one really
knows it's a point thing because we do
know that was invented we don't know why
it's stuck around but it's stuck around
because it's awesome yeah yeah it's
absolutely the one I made for you is
very good the one I made for you was
really good but this is a far better
okay I can't do it I don't know why but
I can't make this magic happen
oh yeah I'm so the burger to get is that
the works its mayo ketchup mustard it's
lettuce tomato
it's a disc a bran ioan pickle salt
pepper it cook the meeting the cheese
separately and then the comes out and
goes in the bunch
cheers Cheers
this is not what I ate at your house the
cheese has this really nice streakiness
to it it's kind of like halloumi or
cheese curds on a poutine the way this
burger works is that it's a loose grind
that's actually loosely packed into
these little trays the tray is going to
the steaming cabinet cook for 10-12
minutes depending on how busy it is in
that steaming box then I thing about
that is if someone can run in here
national burger they're already ready to
go yeah but the nice thing about the
loose grind definitely keeps it keeps it
so it won't doesn't it doesn't become a
dense you know piece of gray matter it's
cooked I mean it's far from that
yeah well this the beef renders yeah but
instead of there being a mired reaction
from a flattop or like a flame reaction
from like the carbonyl compounds of love
like you know what could be on a grill
this is very different this is actually
completely there just it just rendered
beef fat any burger that requires
special equipment special technique will
always have that next level burger
appeal that great this is definitely a
next-level burger pit stop number two
Ted's steamed cheeseburger the regional
oddity here in Connecticut my mind is
blown you've been doing this for years
man yeah do it for a long time you must
know a lot of like skullenbones burger
secrets like you know like I'm sure like
you know stuff that they tell you I've
seen things yeah look yeah I can tell
you oh yeah I see some juicy details on
certain places I can't I would say I
probably have over 50 or 60 different
pieces of very private information that
where they were told me accidentally
that I will never reveal
you've been in oh I watched it though oh
[Laughter]
we did it
[Music]
stopover three classic every first of
all it's just it's admire the place
itself for a second I mean look at this
place
I mean it actually looks like you are
inside of a cheeseburger it's got the
Browns yellows yellows
it's very horizontal like I'd like a
cheeseburger people are still wearing
paper caps you have amazing murals on
the walls I like to describe the mural
behind me as a phantasmagorical
expression of hamburger fantasy yeah
it's almost like when you take your
first bite of a hamburger and like this
time I like what goes through your head
yeah in the beginning it was a dairy
farm and they started to actually sell
milk add a bit of building at the edge
of the dairy farm on the road the winner
had come around they were trying to find
some way to keep business going they got
a grill it started baking sandwiches and
hamburger burger and that's how again if
you thought the steamed cheeseburger was
something else when you see this thing I
could feel it the fairies are telling me
the burners are near hey guys here it is
the Bernice original look at this no
excuse my reach Wow awesome experience
it was the first thing you notice right
away is the smell right but this is
Billy one of the owners everyone thanks
for having us hey Billy hey dude it's
really good to see you hi there there's
some crazy science going on there I know
because not every cheese can to just you
know pop off the griddle not stick right
Cheers
it's an America chase and this is
American cheese made just for you guys
or it's something that we can buy on it
and the more could but it wouldn't work
and then you'd have to come see me so
there's a whole method to the madness
enjoy thanks Billy thank you thank you
this is actually four slices of American
cheese four sizes and there's a kaiser
roll yeah well at one pad single patty
single patty there's probably some type
of pickle in there yep so the way it
works why they actually take four slices
of cheese sort of make a cross a pattern
on the top of the burger so that a lot
of the cheeses are hanging off at that
point people eat a different ways some
people just go and hit
just go in there or I bet you take the
top off and fold the extra cheese in so
you actually have the sort of crispy
cheese thing going on and see that oh
and now you eat the burger it's like a
crunch wrap yeah like it's like a
pinwheel of cheese yeah Wow
it's like a gooey cheese it the very
cheesy burger I'm getting bread
crunch crunch meat yep like Guzzi cheese
and bread so on season one we did a
whole episode on son burgers it's like
to captivate an audience on Instagram
Twitter or social media in every sense
of the case this burger is the same kind
of burger right but it predates all of
that by about seven decades seven
decades the people who invented this
burger knew like hey you eat with your
eyes first so you could obviously get
the cheese crisps on your burger yeah
it's really cool about this place is
that I think it's actually off menu item
let me brown the menu you could actually
order the cheese crisps alone look at
this thank you very much fun yes look at
that yeah Cheers I can sell this I coach
how I make so much money
your experience at Shady Glen is not
completely less you've had ice cream on
the ice cream made here so lately here
we go oh what'd you get dude oh I got
chocolate malt ooh
exactly the same sip you don't mind this
mine is a mocha peanut butter malt you
know and that's again next level next
level oh man
real-deal it's super creamy you're on a
dairy farm another one oh it's just some
fresh yeah and now that we've been to
three great examples of hamburgers in
Connecticut you have a favorite I mean
they're all pretty close I can't pick
favorites
I'll do that but you know I can honestly
say that like tasting a burger at Louise
it was it was like facing history and
just knowing that like something that
simple has evolved and so what we just
had right now here at Shady Glen I mean
it was amazing I feel like it's my
life's work and my goal to make sure
people appreciate these kinds of places
that when you walk into a place you have
a great burger or have even have a great
experience then you owe it to them to
walk up and say that was a great
experience that was a great burger
because it gives them the strength to go
on but they know they know they're
special yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up burger world 7ky line of the
burger show smash that like button hit
that subscribe button if not for me for
the segue